évidemment j'appelle au calme j'appelle
à la vérité de l'enquête judiciaire bien
évidemment le plus rapidement possible
dans le quartier Pablo Picasso des fils
entières de voitures calcinées certains
habitants
éteignent eux-mêmes les dernières
flammes
bataille rangée pendant une grande
partie de la nuit dans les rues de
Nanterre des tiers de mortier des feux
d'artifice tirés par des habitants en
colère des tirs qui visent directement
les policiers j'ai décidé de mobiliser
2000 policiers gendarmes pour que dans
la zone de la préfecture de police de
Paris dans les Hauts-de-Seine
singulièrement l'ordre public puisse
être maintenu je m'étonne et je m'élève
contre les réactions qui aujourd'hui
stigmatise la police la police fait son
travail et elle le fait dans des
conditions souvent difficiles par
exemple Clémentine Autain les images du
jeune homme tué par un tir de policiers
à Nanterre sont terrifiantes que
reste-t-il de notre État de droit si un
délit comme le refus d'obtempérer vaut
une exécution sommaire j'appelle tout le
monde au calme à la retenue parce qu'il
ne faudrait pas que cela s'embrasse il
ne faut pas qu'il y ait d'autres drames
qui interviennent à la suite de celui-ci
les images choquantes diffusées hier
montre une intervention qui ne semble
manifestement pas conforme aux règles
d'engagement de nos de l'ordre est-ce
que ce policier était en danger de mort
pour utiliser son arme c'est ce que
montrera l'enquête judiciaire a priori
des images que l'on a tous vu ne sont
choquantes parce que ça ne correspond
pas à la loi 2017 nous avons un
adolescent qui qui a été tué cette
inexplicable inexcusable et d'abord je
ce sont des mots d'affection de peine
partagée de soutien à sa famille et à
ses proches est-ce que l'acte est
inexcusable
est-ce qu'il est
inexplicable c'est à la justice de
répondre c'est à l'enquête qui va se
dérouler de savoir si il existe une
explication à ce geste choquant bien sûr
si ce jeune est mort c'est d'abord parce
qu'il a cherché à se soustraire à un
contrôle et que les conséquences de ce
comportement aurait pu être
potentiellement dramatique pour d'autres
personnes à proximité pour d'autres
potentiel
s victimes plusieurs personnalités se
sont exprimées sur les réseaux sociaux
et ont appelé à la justice comme le
footballeur Killian Mbappé j'ai mal à ma
France une situation inacceptable
laupestre très rapidement a décidé de
politiser ce qui s'était passé voilà on
voit à l'instant ces images d'élus de la
nupesse qui tiennent une feuille avec
écrit justice et vérité pour Naef ou
l'acteur
Omar Sy qu'une justice digne de ce nom
au nord la mémoire de cet enfant
moi je je pense que le racisme dans la
police est quand même un sujet qu'on a
c'est un sujet qui est absolument
systémique et la France on peut pas ne
pas on peut pas dire qu'il y a pas de
racine dans la police en France ça ça a
été démontré à plusieurs reprises il y a
un racisme qui est systémique on sait
que dans ces affaires là et bien il y a
beaucoup d'entrave à la vérité il y a
des entraves à l'intérieur de la police
lors de l'enquête il y a des entraves à
l'intérieur de la police des polices et
il peut y avoir des entraves du parquet
donc ça va pas de choix et les familles
qui s'engagent là-dedans c'est pour ça
que ça prend cet ampleur là il y aura
des sanctions administratives si il est
avéré en effet comme le montre
manifestement les images que ces gestes
sont absolument pas conformes aux
instructions et à la loi de de la
République que ce soit des
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
que ce soit des gendarmes font face tous
les jours à une pression de plus en plus
forte et forcé de constater que
notamment je le dis notamment en
banlieue parisienne ils sont devenus des
cibles en 2022 c'est 13 morts sur les
refus d'obtempérer donc dans un texte ne
fonctionne pas et qui est l'occasion de
démarches je pense qu'il faut y mettre
fin un refus d'obtempérer qui se traduit
par une peine de mort quel que soit la
situation rien ne justifie quand tu
quelqu'un tout sourire presque fier de
son geste ce touriste a priori américain
et pourtant rechercher dans toute
l'Italie son délit avoir gravé son nom
et celui de sa copine sur le Colisée à
Rome Monsieur Mélenchon ne soutient pas
la police il est pour le désarmement de
la police républicaine et je pense que
ce tweet accompagne la dérive d'un homme
qui est systématiquement du côté de ceux
qui veulent abîmer détruire la
République un acte en apparence
romantique qui pourrait lui valoir 5 ans
de prison